you don't know about pricing that is one
of the limitations of real estate
you have certain indications about
what's going on in the markets but you
don't know
how much your assets are worth
[Music]
sandor valner thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
thank you blessed to be here so good to
have you and so we know each other
through the j
ventures fund you're actually just told
you're you're considered now a rabbi
as a j for the j ventures opening up the
l.a chapter which is wonderful and i get
to work with your
wonderful son as an associate at the
firm and
you know sandor i'd love to spend these
20 minutes getting to know two things
that really i know nothing about
investment banking and latin america
you're from mexico you actually though
you got to study in the mexico hotel in
weizmann institute
and at stanford university both ai
and business and then you go to
investment baking so you're going to
have to give me a little bit of a run
down
how that all happened i'm going to let
you
go from now on sandor talk to me a
little bit about
your background and where you came from
sure uh
born and raised in mexico uh lithuanian
people who escaped the war coming to
united states
couldn't get into the united states
stopped in mexico life but there and
stayed
there was uh we were raised in mexico
and then
um you know started schooling um
initially in mexico then went to the
majon weitzman
for a year where in mexico did you live
mexico city
i was just there for a week with my good
friend from stanford santiago
beautiful place it's uh it's a great
city highly recommended great
food great people very israeli right i
find i found the people there to be
very similar to israelis in tel aviv
well it's it's a it's a fun it's a fun
city
highly recommended once we get into
normalcy again
uh highly recommended definitely so uh
you know then went to school
uh uh in mexico studied engineering then
went to stanford studied
both business and artificial
intelligence before artificial
intelligence
was what we now know artificial
is uh but uh at least to say it was very
interesting and then i
um started a career of 15 years in
investment banking doing mostly
international mergers and acquisitions
and then shifted my career into
private equity real estate um managed uh
large private equity real estate funds
also mostly internationally
and sold uh uh my
interests in the in the real estate
company last year
and i've since been uh doing angel
investing mostly in proptic
and fintech and uh now i'm starting
um a new uh tech enabled investment
banking path
amazing okay so sandor i'd love to talk
about this intersection of
you know you're in real estate for a
long time you're an expert in real
estate now
just from my understanding when you did
that that was traditional real estate
right not necessarily
you know techie ai powered investment
real estate investing right yeah this
was traditional real estate we did
mostly industrial facilities and we did
uh low-income housing and we did offices
and shopping centers nothing related to
tech
how how big are we talking here is this
like one or two buildings or is this
like
you know 50 60 buildings uh
well it's more we raised up close to two
billion dollars and
and we uh we ended up i don't know how
many properties but probably a couple of
hundred
wow so so so managing two billion
dollars in real estate
is that right uh yes i would manage
public and private uh funds uh wow
most of it this was part of a large
organization and we did
you know when i when i was responsible
you know the the
funds the two billion dollars that i
managed were in
latin america so it was uh an
interesting ride because
you know this crisis that we're living
right now
um i think is my eighth crisis uh
in terms of financial crisis
these countries uh particularly mexico
was having crisis every six years so
unfortunately
you know i've learned to live through a
lot of them and i can only
say to your audience uh that we're
probably gonna have
more of them unfortunately so sandor
what have you learned after eight crises
well i've learned that most of the
fortunes uh on the economic side
are made in the crisis uh don't waste
my gsb professor last quarter told me
michael don't waste a good crisis
absolutely absolutely the other thing is
that i think my you know the biggest
learning experiences are during the
crisis they're just very intense periods
where you
are forced to really go uh back to
basics um so you know in terms of
learning and in terms of
eventually making money even though it
seems
uh extremely hard at the time um
or or or carving a successful career
obviously it's not only about money
they're just very good opportunities
although
one when you're in the middle of the
storm they're no fun
right no no definitely okay so now you
know going back to this
idea you you're managing two billion
dollars in in you know real estate
assets
and now you're investing in in startups
that are you know doing prop tech so
what what is property technology and
what specifically about it
makes you excited you know with your
expertise looking at real estate as a
whole
well i think what happened when i when i
left private equity real estate
um during my years uh investing in real
estate i i just found that it's
a industry that is very opaque uh
very inefficient um
and there are many many dimensions
which of real estate which i think can
be improved with
with technology and given what are some
of them
what are some of the really like opaque
parts of it
well but pricing right uh you know when
you
uh when you release a
space office space you don't really know
what everything else is
leasing for uh you don't really
you don't really know what the terms of
the lease
uh are for competitors uh
you don't know um uh you know who's
doing what as you do for example in the
stock market where there's a very
liquid and transparent uh market and i
think at the end of the day
uh the lack of liquidity and
transparency and all this friction
ends up costing everybody all right so i
think we would all be better off if we
had
a more fluid um system
okay so so we're talking about pricing
this idea that
you're able to leverage and deep
technology to really
understand markets and understand how to
price better are there other aspects of
real estate that
the technology can really go into many
for example i'm an
investor in a company that is looking to
disrupt the construction management
industry and the construction management
you've got architects engineers the
owners the bankers the
uh the accountants the contractors
everyone interacting and they don't
interact in a single platform so
everybody speaks different languages uh
decisions take forever there are a lot
of inefficiencies
uh we're trying to build a company that
will
uh it's a collaboration tool that where
everybody can
share information real time and uh
increase efficiencies in construction
right actually two this year two friends
of mine from the gsb were working
on a product where they they came with
the hypothesis
that they can look at email
conversations between you know
contractors architects and builders
and find and predict how much the
project is going to be delayed
so that they can warn in advance because
usually a delay means
more money right i haven't done
construction myself but from my
understanding a delay means money
and so if you can predict ahead of time
that there's poor communication
and therefore delay is going to come
about you can actually save quite a bit
of money and i think more importantly
you're going to save quite a bit of
headache for all parties please
please ask your friends to give me a
call because we're trying to build
really a
a platform to do exactly that to predict
delays uh avoid delays uh and
and uh cost overruns i'm going to
because i actually believe that the one
of the founders
she has a she did her phd on this and
she actually already had something
working so
something positive already came out of
this talk but but sandor back to you
you're you're dealing with you're
dealing with this you're also part of j
ventures what why
go into real estate in the first place
what got you excited about real estate
and why real estate
in mexico and whether you know the us
europe israel why mexico
well why mexico because i happen to be
born there
and and uh my family have historically
been in
in real estate and i had kind of been
bred in
in real estate and it's uh it's a nice
uh it's a nice business and a stable
business and it also
offers uh the possibility of uh creating
a lot of jobs
and improving the you know the standard
of living of
wherever you're you're you're acting and
again i
you know i thought that it was an
industry that
is fairly inefficient and when were
there inefficiencies there are
opportunities to have fun to innovate to
make money etc
right okay and now you're now you you
have your own startup
uh talk to me a little bit about this
one
yes we created a company called network
uh
bankers it's a tech enabled um
investment bank we we've put together
uh we now have a network of over 30 000
uh ceos around the world that are part
of our network
and we're providing investment banking
and investment management
services uh to that
group of 30 000 ceos so so what does
that mean
investment banking services so
basically investment banking what i mean
by investment banking services in this
context is
uh helping these ceos uh
advising them on raising capital raising
debt
or helping them buy or sell companies
okay okay so these are not ceos
necessarily of early stage startups
that are you know just raising a few
hundred thousand dollars i'm guessing
these are
you know later on in their life cycle
they are i mean there's certainly
there's some
um startup ceos where we can raise uh
help them raise
venture capital money but most of most
of these ceos
manage smaller middle-sized uh
companies and um there's some of them
that
manage 100 million dollar companies plus
but most of them are smaller
and we will help them um you know
reach their goals by helping them buy
other companies out or selling divisions
or raising capital or their financial
engineers
uh helping them accomplish their votes
sure and i have to know what are some of
the biggest challenges of
uh you know managing hundreds of
assets in real estate how often do you
do you know you know their values
because they're the values are
fluctuating
you know especially you know as as you
know in the recent years with
the crisis all the way from 2008 up to
now
how do you even get a good grasp of your
holdings
in my mind i'm imagining you know a team
of 100 analysts
sitting all day and just doing
calculations is that the case or are
there different
approaches to this well i mean
you have several questions uh one of the
questions you asked
uh is about pricing you don't know about
pricing you know
that is one of the limitations of real
estate you have certain indications
about what's going on in the markets but
you don't know
how much your assets are worth you can't
just look at what the guy next to you
sold for
is that on you know what you could but
but they're just you know the
transactions are few and far between
it's not like the stock market where you
have millions of shares that are trading
every day
so they're the transactions are limited
but
in in real estate the the one thing you
do have is that they tend to be
uh large and and discrete uh assets so
you can have a team of
two or three people that are monitoring
you know the
management of an office building or or
shopping center and and and and
their their real estate has typically
you have a team in the real estate fund
you have a team that does for example
acquisitions
uh basically you evaluate new
investments and then you have another
team that does asset management which
really means that you have a team that
is monitoring your existing investments
they're
making sure that the offices are well
managed that the
the the released that the they have
adequate uh
debt uh et cetera et cetera so you have
uh
an external team that even though these
funds tend to be rather small funds we
you tend to outsource a lot of this
asset management so you end up
having hundreds of people as you say
monitoring all of these assets
not directly employed by the funds but
indirectly from
uh asset management companies right
right
the this you know studying ai in the
engineering school of stanford and of
course the business school
did that bring a different paradigm to
your thinking behind running the
business
or how to leverage uh different
technologies to help you
how do how do you see that education or
that part of
yourself and your background play into
the role of this
of these great investment banking
endeavors
well i i think the the computer science
background helped me organize my
thoughts and help me
look into things as to how they can be
scaled
um and and uh and
automated uh so i think in the back of
my mind
i always have that whenever kind of a
big or difficult
problem came about uh ai didn't really
play much of a role because when i
studied ai
in in 1985 or so
you didn't have the algorithms that you
have right now
the learning algorithms just didn't
exist so
it was actually fairly frustrating that
we were a little bit ahead of our times
in terms of technology couldn't do much
with it we didn't have the computer
power we didn't uh
we didn't really have the the knowledge
of the required algorithms
um so actually
uh enlightening it was really exciting
once i left
real estate uh discover these new things
that have
been developed in artificial
intelligence and now i can i have a new
toy
that i can play with right i mean this
is this is a fascinating technology
incredible so you know i'm really
i feel like a young kid with a new toy
uh
trying to you know explore something
something different
and and going back to the beginning of
the conversation
trying to piece all of the different
parts of my career into something that
makes sense which probably
never will make sense but you know it
you it's
it's an interesting jigsaw puzzle that
that you assemble throughout your career
but it's been a lot of fun
no definitely you know i go into a our
our computer vision course website and
the notorious cs231n
it's the masters it's the you know
graduate school class for
for convul neural networks for computer
vision
and the first thing that you see on the
website is a neural network
that is able to take an image and
classify it and it's running on the
browser and i can just imagine you know
to me coming in as a new student
and seeing this fresh and having all the
tools at my disposal with a few lines of
code
and my own personal computer or whether
it's amazing or whether it's crappy i
can still run all those
algorithms even you know on my phone i'm
sure it's a very different learning
experience than in 1982 or 1984
and learning about these algorithms
senator i i'm very curious
you know looking from up from very
high to now going down buying
real estate especially for young
individuals
all the time i hear in the news about
you know the american dream to own a
house to own an apartment
israel also people my age are constantly
thinking about okay when am i finally
going to be able to make my first real
estate investment what is your take on
this is this a rational thing to do as a
young
person and to to go and and and run
after a real estate investment
is it better in your mind to you know to
put it somewhere
and to put it somewhere else or is it is
it just like a sexy fad
or is there a real meaning behind it
well i think you have to go back to
basics
uh you know real estate has been a
relatively stable asset it doesn't mean
that it's
not has its risks but as long as you
don't have a lot of
leverage of debt on it it's a fairly
stable
asset but going back to basics
i mean one of the things that these
crises uh
teach you is that you should save right
you really should
say for a rainy day because you don't
really know when we're going to be
quarantined or when there's going to be
a slowdown or when you're going to lose
your job
etc second thing you'll you'll learn is
that you
really need to diversify your assets so
you're going to be
invested in real estate that's great but
you know i don't think anyone should
have you know 99 of their assets in real
estate
all right even though i love wheels
right i mean you should diversify
why because you know you shouldn't have
all your eggs in one basket you should
have it in a few baskets because things
happen
right right but all in all uh real
estate
uh one as an investment is stable it
certainly
plays a role but more importantly it's
it's it's your house right so you know
you
use it and you should you should uh you
should enjoy it
and uh fortunately in in this country
which by the way is not the case in most
countries in the world
uh the loan
rates the interest rates are so low that
a lot of people can afford
buying houses even if they're small at
the beginning this is not the case in
many
in many countries right unfortunately
these crises make
uh houses less affordable so it's you
know it's
tougher but you know this is a tough
time but we're going to have
better times as well so be patient
a hundred percent 100 sender i want to
thank you again for for this time and
and for all the great insights before we
leave
i have to put you on the spot and ask
you my favorite question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that your gsb classmates would use to
describe you or your partners
three words to describe well um
it's a good life it's good like well
it's for
it's a story
start companies take risks um
that was worth much more than three
words trust me
great thank you so much sandor thank you
take care say hi to your son for me
and uh and stay safe and stay healthy
we'll do
thanks again bye bye
you